Lucia: 等我把这个开了再去洗个手
Lucia: Let me turn this on first, then I'll go wash my hands.
Lucia: 然后嗯好了
Lucia: Okay, done.
Lucia: 哎呀我想把这放桌子上
Lucia: Oh, I want to put this on the table.
Lucia: 每天口袋里揣俩锂电池
Lucia: I carry two lithium batteries in my pocket every day.
Lucia: sorry没有没有
Lucia: Sorry, no, no.
Lucia: 想走那个啥
Lucia: I wanted to go to that...
Lucia: 小心
Alice:哎我删掉美颜了
Jake:我没有我没有把薇薇叫起来
Jake: I didn't wake up Tasha.
Jake:路亚也没有叫起来所以我们要齐心协力
Alice:他没醒
Alice: He didn't wake up.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:我打电话他也没有接
Jake: I called him but he didn't answer.
Lucia: 有可能是没醒
Lucia: 因为应该不会在外面
Lucia: Because he shouldn't be outside.
Jake:对
Lucia: 对但是反正我刚敲了几次门
Lucia: Yeah, but I knocked on the door a few times.
Lucia: 但是好像没醒
Lucia: But it seems like he didn't wake up.
Jake:凭什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: Why though? Hahaha.
Lucia: 这就是见证奇迹的时刻
Lucia: This is the moment to witness a miracle.
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why though?
Alice:你收拾一下起来吧
Alice: Clean up and get up.
Alice:OK了充电宝呢
Alice: Okay, where's the power bank?
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why though?
Lucia: 可能是某种心灵感应
Lucia: Maybe it's some kind of telepathy.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Jake:厉害太厉害了
Jake: Amazing, truly amazing.
Jake:这这个快没电了
Jake: This thing is almost out of power.
Jake:不过你也可以用就是
Jake: But you can still use it.
Alice:14好
Alice: Fourteen is good.
Jake:对你先把它用完吧
Jake: Yeah, you finish it first.
Alice:14好数字
Lucia: 14可以用挺久的
Lucia: Fourteen can last quite a while.
Lucia: 我现在在外面基本上一直连着
Lucia: I'm basically always connected when I'm outside now.
Lucia: 但是60回来还有41
Lucia: But after 60 minutes, there's still 41 left.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:其实暂时咱也不用用
Jake: Actually, we don't need to use it right now.
Jake:就是可以等一个小时再用
Jake: We can wait an hour before using it.
Alice:所以任务没了
Jake:对这是最主要的任务因为我么要跟着他不停
Jake:就是没有他确实我们干不了什么
Lucia: 今天晚上吃什么甜品
Lucia: What dessert are we having tonight?
Jake:不知道啊听
Jake: No idea, listen
Lucia: 搓手手
Lucia: Rubbing hands
Alice:我是不是要解释下我在干嘛
Alice: Should I explain what I'm doing?
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure
Alice:为什么要这样呢
Alice: Why do I need to do this?
Jake:为什么呢为什么呢为什么呢知道吗
Jake: Why, why, why, do you know?
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why?
Alice:AI知道吗
Alice: Does AI know?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea
Alice:因为哎呀
Alice: Because, oh
Alice:是不是不知道有打底裤这个东西
Alice: Do you not know about leggings?
Alice:卷边了好了我已经解释过了
Alice: The edges are curling. Alright, I've explained it.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Lucia: 那我希望AI知道
Lucia: Then I hope AI knows
Lucia: 就是人类的腰带大小是不一样的
Lucia: that human belts come in different sizes
Lucia: 而我这个腰带孔不够细
Lucia: and my belt loop isn't small enough
Lucia: 所以我的裤子总在往下掉
Lucia: so my pants keep falling down
Lucia: 我就要不断提它
Lucia: I have to keep pulling them up
Lucia: AI你听见了吗
Lucia: AI, did you hear that?
Lucia: 学会了吗
Lucia: Have you learned it?
Lucia: 你学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn it?
Jake:学废了
Jake: Learned it
Lucia: 你看我说他很像哎呀
Lucia: You see, I said he looks like, oh
Alice:这上面能上去吗
Alice: Can we go up there?
Jake:上不去
Jake: No, we can't
Alice:哦顾客止步
Alice: Oh, no entry for customers
Alice:他怕我们跳下去吗
Alice: Are they afraid we'll jump off?
Alice:你们刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Alice: Did you guys really knock normally just now?
Lucia: 真的是
Lucia: We did
Jake:挺正常的
Jake: It was pretty normal
Alice:可能我没有心灵感应
Alice: Maybe I don't have telepathy
Alice:一个啊我的衣服没拿
Alice: Ah, I left my clothes behind
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:有活吗
Jake: Any work?
Jake:饱和了
Jake: It's all saturated.
Shure: 再把那个拿过来吧
Shure: Bring that over here.
Shure: 然后这个
Shure: And this one.
Jake:好的好大活
Jake: Okay, big job.
Lucia: 有地放不这这
Lucia: Is there enough space here?
Shure: 有有有你先放这边
Katrina: 你觉得少点什么味吗
Katrina: Do you think it's missing some flavor?
Katrina: 像那个浣衣女
Katrina: Like that laundry woman.
Katrina: 山竹
Katrina: Mangosteen.
Katrina: 这要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should this go in the fridge?
Lucia: 对我也在想啊
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 这个反正一会要哎好多水
Lucia: Anyway, we'll roast it later, oh there's a lot of water.
Lucia: 这个一会要烤对吧
Lucia: We need to bake this later, right?
Lucia: 那应该不用放
Lucia: Then it shouldn't need to go in.
Lucia: 我把山竹放下好了
Lucia: I'll just put the mangosteen down.
Lucia: 咱别忘了还有这个
Lucia: Let's not forget we also have this.
Lucia: 然后还有土豆
Lucia: And we have potatoes too.
Jake:哎呀早上好呀
Jake:做什么大厨
Jake: What are we making, chef?
Lucia: 哇我们居然还有
Lucia: Wow, we even have...
Lucia: 我们竟然还买了煎牛排好酷啊
Lucia: We actually bought steaks to pan-fry, how cool!
Katrina: 两盆肉所有都放进来了
Shure: 需要腌的都放进来
Shure: Put everything that needs marinating in.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Okay, and then?
Shure: 这些大概两斤多肉
Shure: This is about two pounds of meat.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 然后12个鸡翅
Shure: And 12 chicken wings.
Jake:请
Shure: 一斤不到一斤排骨
Shure: Less than a pound of ribs.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Hmm, and then?
Alice:这是谁的水吗
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina: 没有这是外外卖买的是
Katrina: No, it was bought from the takeaway.
Jake:没开过哦
Jake: It hasn't been opened.
Shure: 啊我
Shure: Ah, I...
Shure: 我为了配配那什么然后带的
Shure: I brought it to match with something.
Shure: 随便打开
Shure: Just open it.
Shure: 打开就行
Shure: Open it, it's fine.
Jake:我们做什么
Jake: What are we making?
Alice:一个很有品位的水
Alice: A very tasteful water.
Jake:做什么芒果
Jake: Why are you making mangoes?
Shure: 帮我拍个视频什么的谢谢你
Shure: Help me take a video or something, thanks.
Katrina: 要拍到脸吗
Katrina: Should I get your face in the shot?
Shure: 不用拍了脸拍了手就行
Shure: No need for the face, just the hands.
Alice:嗦芒果糊
Alice: Suck the mango puree.
Lucia: 土豆是今天晚上吃的吧同志们
Lucia: The potatoes are for dinner tonight, right, everyone?
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Shure: 做一做马杀鸡
Shure: Let's do a massage.
Jake:是是吧烤土豆
Jake: Yes, roasted potatoes.
Shure: 这感觉料酒可以再倒一点对
Shure: I feel like we can add a bit more cooking wine, right?
Lucia: 是的那我就把它拆开了
Lucia: Yeah, I'll just open it up then.
Jake:拆吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Lucia: 这个可以用来暂时性的放一下
Lucia: This can be used temporarily for now.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Alice:你再给他做马杀鸡
Alice: You're giving him a massage again?
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Katrina: 说独家秘方
Katrina: Talk about the secret recipe.
Katrina: 敬请期待
Katrina: Stay tuned.
Alice:独家秘方
Alice: Secret recipe.
Alice:咋调的呀
Alice: How is it made?
Katrina: 他妈祖传的
Katrina: It's passed down from his mother.
Jake:始于秦始皇时期哪一年
Jake: Dating back to the Qin Shi Huang era, which year was it?
Katrina: 哈哈哈终于修硕
Shure: 不多
Shure: Not much.
Alice:公元前多少年
Alice: How many years before Christ?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Jake:终于修硕
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈他妈的
Shure: Hahaha, damn it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 你这话我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you this.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈祖传
Shure: Hahaha, passed down.
Shure: 然后终于修硕是吧
Shure: 怎么我这边就意思是无出其右了
Shure: So what I mean is, it's unparalleled.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:意思是无出其右了
Alice: Meaning it's unparalleled.
Lucia: 意思是
Lucia: It means
Jake:发扬发扬光大
Jake: To carry forward and expand
Alice:知道没有人能超越你了
Alice: Knowing that no one can surpass you
Shure: 知道没有人超越
Shure: Knowing that no one surpasses you
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:就后面后来者再没有人能够超过你了
Alice: So no one coming after can surpass you
Jake:独树一帜
Jake: Unique
Shure: OK太牛逼了嘎嘎行
Shure: Okay, that's awesome, really cool
Katrina: 新的流派
Katrina: A new style